I wish you had run for president I think
you would win in a landslide right now
and you know that - is there any regret
no there's no regret there's no real I'm
doing I'm doing I'm doing what I said I
would do and when you are doing that and
you've been true to yourself and you're
true to the relationships around you you
have no regrets and that's the most
important thing I tell my kids who are
now with me because of this craziness
but I've actually had a chance to spend
some time with them and real quality
time where they're not running in and
running out yeah it's no regrets is the
most important thing to end the game
with right right and you won't have
accomplished everything you wanted but
that's okay but no regrets that you
honored yourself and you honored your
word and you wanted your commitment and
you did the right thing when you were a
kid and you saw your father never really
you know ran for president did you did
you know what age did you know you were
gonna be a politician that you were
gonna run for office how old were you at
that point when it when it really dawned
on you it's something you wanted to do
my late teens my late teens you know my
father communicated such a passion for
his job such a love and how public
service was an artform
you know everybody's talking about
politicians and the grub enos and he
elevated it to an art form
and how the way he communicated at
Howard everything else was second you
know he would say literally unless you
go into a religious order and dedicate
your life to God
everything else is second the public
service because public service is about
helping other people in its purest form
and when it's done right it makes a
significant impact on people government
doesn't do its job here this is a
situation that is unparalleled and it
will change the course of people's lives
depending on how this is in
you